foreign
is with us in Pullman Washington hi Dean
how are you
can get
up better than I deserve what's up
well first I just want to say it's an
honor to talk to you
um
I have a question regarding uh piece of
scripture and then wealth
and you probably definitely know it but
it's in Mark 10 and he talks about
that it's easier for a camel to enter
through the eye of the needle than a
rich man to enter the kingdom of God my
question is
what is your advice on how to take that
verse into account when establishing a
life and investing and essentially
Building Wealth
um yeah what's your advice on that
well I appreciate your question I'm
gonna send you a copy of the book The
Legacy Journey and I unpack the Rich
Young Ruler I had quite links there but
I'll give you a radio version of that
story
because it's something that comes up a
lot these days
um the concept being obviously a camel
cannot go through the Avenue which means
if you just take that exact scripture
exactly the way you read it then rich
people are not going to heaven
right right
well this is a bit problematic uh from a
practical standpoint for two reasons one
reason is this if you make thirty nine
thousand dollars a year
which is uh about 40 percent of the uh
or about I'm sorry about sixty percent
of the average household income in
America you are in the top one percent
of income earners in the entire world
yeah so if you live in North America and
you make thirty nine thousand dollars a
year if you take that scripture the way
you presented it
most people listening to this right now
are going to hell
well that's a little absurd when you
think about it okay number one uh so we
kind of have to then we have to pan back
and go okay so what's wrong with
the equation that I was using to look at
that what's wrong with this well
uh number one in the in the first
century following Christ there was a
group of Heretics called the gnostics
and the gnostics believed that and
they're still gnosticism in the world
today the gnostics believe that anything
of um
of substance so anything of material was
evil and only the spiritual was holy
so things like fill the you know filthy
money that kind of thing came up then
and anything that anything had to do
with wealth anything that had to do with
owning a shirt uh anything that is
physical is by definition evil even they
thought their own bodies were evil uh
where our scripture in Evangelical
Christianity believes that uh that God
you know is blessing us and loves us and
created good things for us and in living
in abundance now
the big deal with this is the gnostics
were Heretics because they believed that
you could not go to heaven if you had
material Goods much like we were just
discussing
now why is that why is that heretical
why does that make you a heretic if you
believe that because those of us that
are followers of Jesus believe that the
blood of Jesus At The Cross Jesus's
sacrifice
when you believe when you believe on
that that you're going to heaven whether
you were a murderer
before whether you were a prostitute
before
or even a rich person before yeah but if
the blood of Heaven is good enough to
get a prostitute or a a murderer into
heaven and it's not good enough to get a
rich person into heaven that is heresy
follow me
yeah because you're breaking down the
work that was done at the cross now
we're having a very biblical Christian
discussion here but it's a very biblical
question Christian question and so it's
the only way to address it now let's go
back to that particular story and pan
out just a little bit
because you can take a single line of
scripture and completely create a toxic
movement over it if you don't take it in
context
and so pan back a little bit let's go
back to the whole story number one where
did this occur
it occurred in Jerusalem Jerusalem was
the home of the spiritual Elite the
Pharisees and the Sadducees and if you
were a Rich Young Ruler you were by
definition part of the religious Elite
if you were in Jerusalem now if this had
occurred in Galilee he might have been a
merchant
but the uh because the merchants would
have been the wealth holders there but
since it occurred in Jerusalem We Know
by definition from historical fact that
he was a part of the religious Elite
which Jesus by the way had very little
use for if you remember
and so he walks up and says good teacher
what have I got to do to enter Heaven
and the good teacher says you have to
keep the law and he said I've done this
since my youth which of course is
impossible no one keeps the law of pause
completely but and so that was an
arrogant butt statement yeah okay but
Jesus plays along and says okay now that
you've done that let's prove it sell all
that you have and give it to the poor
and he goes away with his head hung low
because by the way the wealth that he
had gotten he did not earn the wealth
that he had gotten had been given to him
because of his status in the religious
community
and he went away with his head hung low
because he was a person of great wealth
Jesus turned to the crowd and said it's
harder for a camel to get harder for
rich man to get into heaven than his
camel to get through the Avenue right
and that's where it is now here's where
the magic happens not magic here's where
the answer happens you keep reading
keep reading and the disciples then are
amazed
they were amazed that rich people can't
get to heaven
and Jesus turns and says no one does
no one gets to the father except through
the son
so this was not a teaching on wealth is
a prohibitor to Heaven this is a
teaching on Grace that the only way to
him
to to the father is through the son and
that's what yeah that's what that's what
Bible Believers believe but then what
happens is people either a uh they have
an extra grind they're jealous they have
problems they're socialists they're
whatever they are and they want to get
in and figure out that that somehow
Christianity is inconsistent or hip or
full of Hypocrites and they pull one
line of scripture out of the story out
of historical context and out of the
context of what Jesus was actually
talking about the reason the story is
recorded is because of that final line
where Jesus looks at him and says one
way yeah to the father through the son
yeah through him and even the even the
rich people yeah
so that's the answer to your question
Dean so then it becomes okay who what
are we called to do as Believers we are
called to manage not to own we're called
to be kind and generous we're called to
do good with the money that we take care
of first step is take care of your own
household first or you're worse than
unbeliever scripture
and then you work your way through and
you're supposed to manage things for the
good of the Kingdom if you are a
believer
and that's what you're called to do and
so the last time I checked poor people
aren't feeding hungry kids